5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY AND THIS
IS "THE FIVE."
THE MEDIA IS FREAKING OUT AFTER
MONTHS OF LEGAL TRAUMA AND
UNCERTAINTY.
ELON MUSK IS CLOSING IN ON HIS
BLOCKBUSTER DEAL TO BUY TWITTER
WITH A STATED GOAL OF RESTORING
FREE SPEECH.
THE WORLD'S RICHEST MAN MAKING A
SURPRISE OFFER TO GO THROUGH
WITH HIS BID TO BUY THE
SOCIAL MEDIA GIANT ON THE TERMS
HE ORIGINALLY AGREED TO.
SOME IN THE PRESS ARE NOW VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT IT.
ONE REPORTER WARNINGS THE
OUTCOME OF THE MIDTERMS COULD BE
IMPACTED TWEETING THIS "FOR
THOSE OF YOU ASKING YES, I DO
THINK THIS SITE CAN AND WILL
CHANGE PRETTY DRAMATICALLY IF HE
HAS FULL CONTROL OVER IT.
NO, THERE IS NO IMMEDIATE
REPLACEMENT IF IT GETS DONE
EARLY ENOUGH BASED ON THE PEOPLE
HE'S ALIGNED WITH, YES, IT COULD
ACTUALLY AFFECT THE MIDTERMS."
OTHERS ON THE MEDIA DON'T LIKE
IT EITHER.
>> I HESITATE TO ASK WHAT COULD
ELON MUST BE THINKING PEER THAT
IS A RECIPE FOR A DISASTER.
>> HAVE YOU EVER BEEN TO A
WEDDING WHERE -- YOU SHOULDN'T
BE GETTING MARRIED.
THIS IS NOT GOING TO WORK OUT.
THIS IS KIND OF WHAT IS
HAPPENING.
SPEAK WITH A PLAN TO REINSTATE
DONALD TRUMP ONTO TWITTER.
>> I DON'T NEED TO BE THERE FOR
THAT.
I'M NOT ONTO SOCIAL FOR A RECENT
APPEARANCE BEFORE THE FIGHT FOR
FREE SPEECH IS A BIG DEAL FOR
ELON MASK TO CENSOR
"THE NEW YORK POST" AND THE
STORY.
HUNTER'S BUSINESS ASSOCIATE TONY
BOBULINSKI SPEAKING OUT ABOUT
THE CENSORSHIP LAST NIGHT.
>> I'M COMING OUT NOW BECAUSE
STILL BEING LATE TO THE FACTS.
I DON'T WANT TO SIT HERE IN
DECEMBER WHEN THEY ACTUALLY HAND
TIGHT HUNTER BIDEN AND THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE LIKE WHY
WERE WE NOT MADE AWARE OF THE
FACTS?
THIS IS CRAZY.
I WOULD CHOOSE MY VOTE FOR THAT
CONGRESSMAN, SENATOR, THAT
GOVERNOR OR ATTORNEY GENERAL.
MY EMAIL ADDRESS WAS THERE.
I'M EASY TO GET A HOLD OF.
PEOPLE HAVE NEVER REACHED OUT
AND SAID, "HEY, 20
"THE NEW YORK POST" JUST
PUBLISHED AN EMAIL TO YOU BUT IS
IT REAL?
CAN YOU PRODUCE THE EMAIL TO
ASK?
"5 MINUTES OF TWITTER, FACEBOOK
OR ANYBODY ELSE WHO REACHED OUT
I WOULD PRODUCE AN EMAIL.
>> Dana: GREG, THE JOURNALIST
TO SAY THAT TWITTER COULD AFFECT
THE MIDTERMS, DOESN'T THAT MEAN
IT IS AFFECTING THE MIDTERMS
NOW?
>> Greg: S, I THINK THEY USED
THE PHRASE "EFFECT" BUT YOU KNOW
WHAT THEY MEAN.
IT IS A VALUE NEUTRAL TERM BUT
YOU KNOW WHAT THEY ARE TALKING
ABOUT.
THEY TELL YOU THEY KNOW THE JIG
IS UP, RIGHT?
LIKE SQUATTERS REALIZE THE OWNER
IS COMING BACK TO THEIR HOUSE
AND THAT BETTER COVER UP THE RUG
STAINS WITH FURNITURE.
THAT IS WHAT IS HAPPENING RIGHT
NOW.
I THINK THEY DO REALIZE THEY HAD
A RUN ON THIS THING.
BUT YOU GOT TO REMEMBER, YOU
KNOW THERE IS A LOT OF
INTERESTING THINGS MOST PEOPLE
ARE NOT ON TWITTER.
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE ON TWITTER
OR THE MEDIA SPECIFICALLY AND
THEY MISTAKENLY BELIEVE THE
ATTITUDES AND ASSUMPTIONS
ON TWITTER REFLECT THE COUNTRY'S
THOUGHTS.
NO, IT IS THE MEDIA CYCLING
THROUGH THEIR OWN THOUGHTS OVER
AND OVER AGAIN.
IT IS INTERESTING BECAUSE THESE
ARE THE PEOPLE THAT USE AND
ABUSE TWITTER MOST AND THE
PEOPLE WHO NEED IT LEAST.
RIGHT?
IF YOU ARE IN THE MEDIA, YOU
HAVE YOUR WHAT DO YOU CALL IT,
MEGAPHONE.
THEY RUN TO TWITTER AND NEED IT
MORE APPEAR THERE IS A SENSE OF
DESPERATION THEY ARE LOSING...
THEY ARE LOSING A CRUTCH.
TWITTER WAS THEIR.
THEY COULD ACTUALLY FIND THEIR
OPINIONS FOR TWITTER.
A LITTLE OPINION TREE AND IF YOU
DIDN'T KNOW WHAT TO THINK
ABOUT, LET'S SAY, GENDER
AFFIRMATION SURGERY AND IS IS SO
COMPLICATED, YOU CAN GO AND PICK
YOUR LITTLE OPINION ON TWITTER
AND JOE SAY, OH, THIS WILL HELPH
OF A CONFUSED TEEN OR WHATEVER
YOU WANT.
OR SOMETHING ABOUT YOU KNOW
WHAT, THESE ARE DOMESTIC
TERRORISTS WHO ARE THREATENING
THE TEACHERS UNION APPEAR THEY
HAVE IT ALL BE SET FOR YOU TO
PULL THEM OUT.
BUT THEY ARE VERY SELFISH
BECAUSE THEY GOT WHAT THEY
WANTED OUT OF THIS STUPID
TWITTER.
THEY ALREADY GOT BIDEN
ELECTED, RIGHT, THROUGH
SELF-CENSORSHIP.
SO YOU GUYS SHOULD BE HAPPY AND
WALK AWAY KNOWING THAT YOU STOLY
BASICALLY MANIPULATING THE
SOCIAL MEDIA NETWORKS IN THESE
TECH TITANS TO DO WHAT YOU WANT
APPEARANCE BEFORE JESSE,
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" REPORTED
"EVERY TWITTER EMPLOYEE WAS
PLANNING TO QUIT, WHICH MIGHT
ACTUALLY HELP" IF YOU ARE
ELON MUSK, YOU DON'T HAVE TO
WORRY ABOUT THAT.
>> Jesse: TWITTER USED TO BE A
REALLY COOL BAR.
IT USED TO LET EVERYBODY AGAIN,
GOOD VIBE, GOOD DRINKS.
AND THEN SOME OF THE REGULARS
STARTED TO COMPLAIN, THE LIB
SPIRIT IT IS TOO LOUD IN HERE.
I DON'T LIKE THE MUSIC AND THIS
GUY BUMPED INTO MY SHOULDER ON
THE WAY BACK TO THE BATHROOM AND
THEY COMPLAIN TO MANAGEMENT.
MANAGEMENT WAS KIND OF STUCK.
AND TONIGHT WE WILL DO SOME
THINGS.
WE WILL HIRE A BOUNCER AND HAVE
VIP ROOM IN THE BACK.
WE WILL HAVE A DRESS CORD AND
ENFORCE AND THEN THINGS STARTED
CHANGING, RIGHT?
THEY STARTED NOT LETTING PEOPLE
IN AND YOU COULDN'T GET A DRINK
ORDER.
AND THE POLICE CHIEF AND MAYOR
WOULD SIT IN THE BACK AND SORT
OF RUN THINGS.
AND THEY GOT EVERYTHING
ACCOMPLISHED.
ALL OF A SUDDEN, CLOSED FOR THE
REGULARS ARE LIKE "THIS PLACE IS
GREAT" AND THE OTHER
REGULARS, "THIS PLACE SUCKS
NOW."
THEN IT GOT REALLY BAD THE
REGULARS WANTING IT STARTED
SELLING NUMBERS OUT OF THE BACK
AND MAY BE PASSING
CASH, ENVELOPES, SEX TRAFFICKING
OUT OF THE BACK.
DOING REALLY DIRTY THINGS.
>> Greg: YOU ARE TAKING THIS
ANALOGY TO THE VERY END.
>> Jesse: I'M NOT FINISHED.
AND NOBODY DID ANYTHING ABOUT
THAT.
IF YOU LIT UP A CIGARETTE, BOOM,
THEY THREW YOU HEAD OUT ON THE
PAVEMENT.
PEOPLE DIDN'T LIKE THAT AND THEY
KNOW ONCE WENT TO THE BAR
ANYMORE.
STARTED TO LOSE CUSTOMERS AND
NEW MANAGEMENT TEAM AND THIS GUY
WANTED TO BUY IT.
THEN THE REGULARS THAT RAN THE
PLACE ARE LIKE "NO, NO, YOU
CANNOT BUY IT BECAUSE YOU WILL
LET EVERYBODY AN END YOU WILL
NOT HAVE A DRESS CODE AND IT
WILL BE FIRST COME,
FIRST SERVED.
I WILL NOT GET A SPECIAL TABLE
AND SPECIAL TREATMENT."
THAT IS WHAT IS GOING ON A BAR
THAT GOT BAD AND NOW IT IS GOOD
AGAIN.
>> Dana: I AM IMPRESSED.
I HAVE TO SAY, THAT WAS
SOMETHING ELSE, JESSE.
THERE WAS THIS LEGAL DISPUTE
THAT WAS GOING ON BETWEEN
TWITTER AND ELON MUSK AND THEN
HE FINALLY SAID, OKAY, I WILL
BUY IT ANYWAY."
>> Judge Jeanine: ELON MUSK
WAS FEARFUL THAT
JUDGE MAGISTRATE WOULD ROLL
AGAINST HIM AND THE TRIAL WAS
SCHEDULED FOR OCTOBER 17TH.
HE SAID, "LOOK, I WILL GO
FORWARD AND BUY IT BUT IN
ADDITION TO THAT, I WANT YOU TO
CANCEL THE TRIAL."
BUT WHAT IS SO AMAZING ABOUT
THIS IS THAT EVERYONE ON THE
LEFT, "OH, MY GOSH, IT WILL
AFFECT THE ELECTION" APPEAR TO
AFRAID THEY WILL REASSURE MIKE
RESHAPE THE ELECTION.
IT IS SO TYPICAL OF THE
DEMOCRACY ON THE LEFT ARE
EVERYTHING THEY ARE AFRAID OF
HAPPENING THEY HAVE ALREADY
DONE.
AND SO LIKE TONY VOTE TONY
BOBULINSKI HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO
TALK TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE THIS
INFORMATION SUPPRESSED ON
SOCIAL MEDIA ABOUT JOE BIDEN AND
HUNTER BIDEN, THAT ELECTION
MIGHT NOT HAVE TURNED OUT THE
WAY IT DID TURN OUT.
BUT NOW THEY ARE SAYING, "OH, MY
GOSH, MY FREE SPEECH, WE CAN'T
HAVE FREE SPEECH."
IT SHOWS YOU HOW QUICKLY THE
LEFT HAS MOVED ITS AGENDA.
WHERE WE HAD TO FIGHT IN
STATING, HEY, IT IS A GOOD
THING, FREEDOM OF SPEECH IS A
GOOD THING.
PEOPLE ARE SAYING, "OH, NO, IT
IS WRONG."
PEOPLE ARE ABLE TO SAY THINGS.
IT IS HYPOCRISY SO OBVIOUS.
THE EMPLOYEES ARE FREAKED OUT.
WHAT ARE THEY SAVING, THE SHOW
SUCCESSION AND TRYING TO FIGUREK
AND THE LAYOFFS ON ALL OF THAT.
YOU KNOW WHAT, MAYBE PEOPLE
DESERVE TO BE LAID OFF.
BEFORE TENS OF THOUSANDS OR
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF FAKE
ACCOUNTS.
>> Judge Jeanine: EXACTLY.
>> Dana: THERE ARE FAKE
REGULARS AT THE BAR, JESSE,
COAST REGULARS.
>> Greg: PEOPLE HOLDING A SEAT
AND THEY ARE NOT THERE.
>> Dana: EXACTLY, JESSICA.
>> Jessica: I WAS NEVER THAT
AFRAID OF ELON MUSK BUYING
TWITTER BECAUSE A LOT OF THE
THINGS HE TO DO ACTUALLY, THEY
WANTED MORE TRANSPARENCY HOW THE
ALGORITHM WORKED AND I THOUGHT
THAT WAS IMPORTANT FOR THEIR
EMPLOYEES.
I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY EXECUTIVES
WILL BE AROUND AFTER HE DOES
TAKE OVER IF HE DOES.
YOU ARE RIGHT OCTOBER 17TH GOING
FORWARD, BUT IT WAS REPORTED A
HALF AN HOUR AGO THE PREFERRED
FINANCING HAS PULLED OUT OF THE
DEAL.
THIS IS NOT A COMPLETED
SITUATION HERE.
THE QUESTION IS NOT ABOUT
FREE SPEECH.
IT IS ABOUT THE LINE FREE SPEECH
AND MISINFORMATION FOR LIBERAL
SPIRIT THAT IS A DIFFICULT LINE
TO TREAD.
BECAUSE THIS WAS PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT DURING THE COVID
PANDEMICS WHEN THE GOVERNMENT
SPOKE TO THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION AND THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION WERE WORKING WITH
THE SOCIAL MEDIA COMPANIES TO
MAKE SURE THERE WAS NOT THAT
INFORMATION GETTING OUT ABOUT
THE DISEASE ITSELF AND ABOUT THE
VACCINE, ET CETERA.
IF THAT IS WHAT PEOPLE'S
PRINCIPAL CONCERN IS HERE.
I'M WAITING FOR ELON MUSK TO
GIVE A GOOD ANSWER BESIDES I
WILL REINSTATE DONALD TRUMP AND
I WILL LET ALL OF THE BOX.
WHAT DO YOU DO ABOUT THE PACT
THAT PEOPLE DO USE THESE TOOLS
TO SPREAD FALSEHOODS THAT ARE
POTENTIALLY DANGEROUS TO THEIR
HEALTH, FOR INSTANCE?
I KNOW THEY HAVE HUGE ARMIES...
BEFORE IT IS INTERESTING THE
CALIFORNIA GOVERNOR AND SOME
SIGNED A LAW THAT SAYS BASICALLY
DOCTORS IN THE PRIVACY OF
THEIR OWN DOCTORS OFFICES CAN
BE...
CAN LOSE THEIR LICENSE FOR
SOMETHING THEY SAY TO THEIR
PATIENT IN PRIVATE BECAUSE THE
GOVERNMENT WOULD DECIDE IT IS
MISINFORMATION.
>> Greg: ONE MISINFORMATION IS
ANOTHER PERSONS MISINFORMATION.
IT IS JUST LIKE IF YOU WERE IN
THE HATE SPEECH ARGUMENT GO
THROUGH A NEW DEFINITION BECAUSE
IT IS A NEW PREDEFINED VERSION
OF HATE SPEECH.
IT IS WHAT YOU DEFINED IT AS SO
IT IS MAINLY A SPIRIT
>> Jessica: IT ISN'T
MEANINGLESS BECAUSE IT IS HOW
DECISIONS LIKE THIS GET MADE
THAT AFFECTS TENS OF MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE.
YOU ARE RIGHT, THE AVERAGE
PERSON IS NOT ON TWITTER AND
THEY DON'T CARE.
THAT IS ONE OF THE MAIN LESSONS
ON THE DEMOCRATIC SIDE WENT
JOE BIDEN WON.
EVERYBODY, THEY ARE NOT BLUE
CHECKMARKS OR PEOPLE GOING
ONLINE.
THEY WORK A NORMAL JOB AND THEY
GO TO THE POLLS AND VOTE FOR A
PERSON AND THE BEST CHANCE OF
WINNING.
BUT BELITTLING PEOPLE'S CONCERNS
OVER THAT INFORMATION AND
MONITORING ACCOUNTS THAT CAN
LEAD TO TERRORISM, THIS IS ONE
OF THE PRINCIPAL CONCERNS.
>> Jesse: I TRUST THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE TO FIND OUT WHAT IS RIGHT
AND WHAT IS WRONG.
WE DON'T NEED BIG GOVERNMENT
TRYING TO LOOK AT ALL THE
ALGORITHMS.
>> Judge Jeanine: AND THE
SUPREME COURT PROTECTS HATE
SPEECH.
IT IS PROTECTED HATE SPEECH.
IT IS UP TO THE INDIVIDUAL TO
DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT THEY
WANT TO FOLLOW, BELIEF OR INVEST
IN HATE SPEECH.
IT IS NOT UP TO THE GOVERNMENT.
WE KNOW FROM WHAT IS HER NAME
SINGING MARY POPPINS.
>> Greg: THAT IS THE PERFECT
EXAMPLE BECAUSE SHE WAS THE
EXPERT WHO TURNED OUT HAD BEEN
LYING ABOUT HUNTER BIDEN'S